the right-hander probably the best
pitcher on the tiger staff right now on
jose
arena he's looking for his second win of
the year
he has pitched seven innings in each of
his last four starts
the longest streak of his career and the
longest by a major league pitcher this
season he had nine walks over his
first two starts and the 3-2 pitch a
ground ball to hold it short and through
bases left field
so nelson has a two out hit the twins
have a man now no score first
inning and the batter is jorge polanco
and that is down the line and cruz
hustling to second
hustling to third the ball stays in the
corner and cruz will be held at third
base a ball hit
right over the first base bag second and
third two outs no score big spot now
in the big league debut for trevor
larnick the 2-2
right back to him off his leg but arena
with a soft toss to jonathan scope and
he escapes any damage twins leave a pair
jose barrios numbers he's had struggles
in detroit he hasn't taken the mountain
actually in detroit since 2018 but he
needs to be the ace today you need to
win this series
now 2-0 to grossman the twins shifting
him to
pull the ball from the left side and he
loves to work quick and he's ready for
you to step in that box
grossman turns on one sends it to deep
right field
god a frozen rope to right
and the tigers draw first blood wow
instant
off the bat of robbie grossman number
three and the tigers take a one-nothing
lead in the first
three for five coming in the game off
with this right-hander so they like to
get up there and that's a big time buggy
with the lead off the ball game
a no doubter off the bat of robbie
grossman that'll get these fans excited
pressure on the minnesota defense
already here in the first
and maybe miggy can keep his good day
yesterday rolling
push to the right side uh ceno with a
great catch
and they'll get a double play with a
tremendous play by
simmons a line drive to sono for the
first out then he nearly fired it into
left field
and acrobatically simmons was able to
catch it
how do you make that catch up right
relax stands for jake cape ground ball
to short
perfectly positioned nico goodroom
fields and fires over to scope one up
and one down rorvette to a two hour walk
2-1 to edelton simmons a line drive to
left but right at robbie grossman
twins are done in the second and missed
the five-pitch walk putting crews aboard
and that'll get polanco to the plate
smacks one to shallow right near the
line played by castro throws to first
and it's not in time
as polanco beat it another sharply
pulled ground ball this time
scope it was to his right and again
two around two are out and an rbi chance
for trevor
sharply hit gloved by scope and
tosses to irania what a play there to
end the third
he took extra bases away from larnock
with a diving stop on a shot
down that first base line well that's a
big time play at the right time
looking for more here in the tigers half
of the third grossman
this one is drilled to right center that
could find the gap
it will and grossman chugs in to second
for a lead off double
he's seen it well well that one is
downgraded to 103 miles an hour shut but
rios not making the adjustment first
time up
grossman over to third leave it up to
miggy to
try to pick up this rbi it's a weak
round ball to third donaldson waits back
he'll pick he'll set he'll throw him out
and that's out number three tigers lead
off double leads to nothing twins only
down one
books have had three hits so far fly
ball left field robbie giving chase
center fielder gonna come over won't get
there as castro
gonna play it on the one hop and it's
gonna be a leadoff double
for jake cave and that snaps it over 14.
first guy to get on to start an inning
for the twins
for miguel cino and he strikes him out
for the second time today
mourinho's got two strikeouts in the
game they're both against cinel and that
was a slider
now the rookie ben rorfett the 2-2 swing
and a miss
back-to-back punch-outs for iranian
after the lead-off double and he's one
out away from getting out of trouble in
the fourth
on the ground to third candelario takes
his time
and throws out simmons one nothing
tigers no mar mazzara leads off with the
tigers in the bottom of the fourth
inning throwing a lot of breaking balls
mazara smokes one to right center that's
gonna find the gap
he'll go second got three easily
cruising into second he makes the turn
headed to third and he's got it with a
pop-up slide
good for him a lead-off triple here to
start the tigers in the fourth
here's niko good 2-2 to good room
that'll do it ace hit to left an rbi
single for nico goodroom
he's going to dig for second head first
slide gets him there
right out of the box he was thinking two
he got it
drove it around it's two nothing tigers
nico hits the line drive gets by simmons
and then warnick just sort of jogging
through the ball niko recognizes that
as mazara scores and he goes hard all
the way into second base
top of the order for minnesota here in
the top half of the fifth inning max
kepper
to center and falls down for a hit
kepler will hold up with a single so a
lead off single for kepler
down a couple of runs now we'll see what
donaldson can get done
there's a drive to left field and we are
tied
just like that they're never really out
of a ball game they're never out of an
inning
it's one of those situations where
you've got power in the middle and
if you're kepler you're able to get on
base like that in front of a guy like
donaldson
who can tie the game with one swing in
the bat hit that ball very hard
got a new ball game michael fulmer he's
on here with one out miguel should know
he bats here with the bases loaded
pop-up shadow right field castro calls
everybody off
got the job done there's two away coming
up for the third time
the 2-2 from fulmer lifted deep right
field
mazzara's got room makes the catch and
michael fulmer
does a terrific job inheriting a bases
loaded jam
harold castro has been spraying line
drives his last
two games grossman on the move castro
slams one to the center
all the way to third hit and run
executed
to perfection runners at the corners
nobody out chamber candelario steps to
the plate
that'll work that's in the air to center
it's dropping
cave has got it grossman tags to throw
home it's cut off by cino
and grossman is thrown out at third base
it's one of those deals where you gotta
commit
robbie went hard and all of a sudden he
decided
uh i'm not going to make it a good spot
here
and the twins are one for nine today
with runners in scoring position
two on two out in the seventh the 3-2
lifted to left field grossman hurry
still coming and he slides and makes the
grab
got a nice break on the ball read it
beautifully and made a sliding third out
the steely stare from michael fulmer in
the seventh heads to the dugout runner
at third
less than two outs and you got your
future hall of famer at the plate
here comes the 2-2 grounded and backhand
stabbed made by
donaldson he's not going to be able to
throw it the tigers take the lead
just a phenomenal stop by donaldson then
he couldn't find the handle
bases are loaded with tigers
and rocco baldelli wants a pitching
change
they are in a tough spot swinging the
fly ball
softly into center field charging hard
as cave he won't get there
rounding third mazara coming home
through the third not in time
to run single for nico goodwin two big
runs with two outs and the tigers take a
5-2 lead
the base is loaded yet again for the
tigers
here in the seventh and here's jake
rogers base hit
left field jones is home
[Music]
so is good room the tigers pad their
lead
on jake rogers two-run single
his first hit of the year gregory soto
was on for the ninth inning for detroit
so back to back two out walks and the
tying one is coming up
in max kepler on the ground to first
castro will take it yes sir the tigers
have tied the series